before we get into how the russian
oligarchs stormed london to make it the
most influential and important russian
center outside the russian motherland
let's talk about how keeps the sponsor
of today's video can help you defend
against hair loss
believe it or not hair loss is a problem
that affects over 60 percent of men
including this man and while there seems
to be solutions out there finding the
right one can be tricky but keeps is a
subscription service where you can
tailor an fda approved solution for your
specific stage of hair loss
unfortunately it's a bit late for me
keeps can only stop hair loss not
regenerate hair so it's best to take
action in the early stages of hair loss
most people see results in around six
months even better you don't have to
leave the house once your treatment plan
is established your products are sent to
you with the correct amounts for daily
use they also have online medical
support because hair loss is a medical
issue and you need to be sure that the
hair loss is not a symptom of something
more serious but don't just take our
word for it head to their website and
check their reviews for before and after
photos of real men who've had success
with this program so if this is a
problem that is bothering you or someone
you care about and you have a u.s
address remember hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com forward slash visualpolitik
or click the link in the description
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
visualpolitik
[Music]
pay attention to this news headline
because it has a lot to do with today's
video
sanctions threatened uk's position as
playground for russian oligarchs first
penalties on russians could hit what
some call moscow ontems but before we
dive into this matter let me ask you a
question do you know how many
millionaires there are in the world 5
million 10 maybe 20. no we are talking
about more than 50 million millionaires
around the world today but perhaps the
most impressive fact is that it is the
vast majority of these cases we are not
talking about inherited wealth three out
of four millionaires today are self-made
that is they created their own wealth
through their own efforts but have you
ever wondered where these people prefer
to live what are their favorite
destinations of the wealthiest people on
the planet well i'm sure you already
know where this is heading because yes
the city with the most millionaires in
the world is not new york or singapore
or dubai or even that little gem called
miami it's london
british capital has around nine hundred
thousand people whose net worth exceeds
one million dollars in other words if
you go to london approximately one out
of every ten people you see on the
street has more than one million dollars
and that's not all london also ranked
seventh on the list of cities in the
world with the most billionaires the
mega-rich more than 60 of them live
around the thames
[Music]
surprised no wonder especially when we
realize that london is not exactly a
city famous for sun beaches and mojitos
at sunset so the question is what on
earth is about london that attracts so
many millionaires okay the short answer
would probably be something like grant
it's obvious that is where the money is
in a way yes that is true london is one
of the great two financial centres of
the world and the other one is of course
new york we are talking about a place
where investors from practically every
corner of the world converge
if you're a government or a large
company and you want to raise a large
amount of funding you will probably be
forced to visit the british capital
nearly 20 percent of all international
bank lending and over 12 of all listed
international bonds originate in the uk
in addition london is also the
derivatives capital of the world and the
centre of more than 40 percent of all
global foreign exchange trading we're
talking about a huge hub for financial
services of all kinds a city which also
houses the european headquarters of
hundreds of multinationals the so-called
soft power low taxes along with the
flexible and non-intrusive regulations
have positioned london as a world
epicenter of financial activity
[Music]
in other words london is a money-making
rocket and people with money like places
where they can make even more money
while keeping their fortunes safe at the
same time i mean come on i don't think
we're reinventing the wheel here what we
are talking about is black and white
legal certainty the fundamental
ingredient required for a country to
prosper
[Music]
but let's not get sidetracked in
addition to all these factors that are
key behind the success of london and in
general of the united kingdom there is
another reason that we can highlight and
that so many of you may not know about
the so-called tier one visa also known
as the golden visa a perhaps brilliant
idea but like everything one that has
its positives and negatives one that has
currently been identified as one of the
means of punishment against russia for
the invasion of ukraine or rather as one
of the means of punishment against the
oligarchs who support vladimir putin
eu lawmakers to push for ban on new
golden passports visas for russians
johnson government ends golden visas for
russian oligarchs
uk crackdown on russian oligarchs may
spell the end for london grad wealthy
elites are being forced to choose
between their wealth their luxury their
future and supporting vladimir putin and
so visualpolitik viewers in this video
we are going to tell you how the uk has
been trying to attract millionaires from
all corners of the world and how this
has become a huge headache because of
the express visas granted to hundreds of
russian oligarchs let's get cracking
[Music]
the visa of the rich
first of all an important note golden
visas are not exclusive to the united
kingdom in fact there are 23 countries
in the world that have such visas each
with their own quirks
even countries such as greece and spain
which are not exactly known for being
the most business friendly places on
earth have such visas linked to
investment in assets such as real estate
stocks or public debt for example in
spain the model was implemented in 2013
with the aim of providing an outlet for
many of the empty properties that
remained unsold when the real estate
bubble burst in 2008. in this way in
spain you can buy your visa if you
acquire properties worth at least 500
000 euros or 547 000 us dollars
in fact post-brexit this has become a
good business for spain and for the
mediterranean countries in general let's
just say that many british people are
considering buying property in order to
obtain a visa to be able to do business
and be able to come and go from
countries like spain without further
limitations
britons now choose eu countries golden
visa schemes to win back their travel
rights which is exactly the same thing
that many russians have also done just
take a look at the mediterranean
coastline in southern spain so at this
point the question many of you may be
asking is why are they only focusing on
the uk's golden visa
[Music]
well you see the truth is that few
countries have had as both much success
and as much controversy with this type
of program as the good old united
kingdom since its implementation in 2008
more than 12 000 millionaires and their
families have seen the british doors
flung open wide for them all thanks to
the tier 1 visa
[Music]
currently and after several
modifications and tightening of the
requirements at least two million pounds
slightly more than 2.5 million dollars
must be invested in companies registered
in the country or in bonds in addition
with this type of visa you can apply for
permanent residency within a certain
number of years a period which is
shortened as the amount of money
invested increases
[Music]
yes in a way it's kind of like buying a
visa and jumping the queue on the
application list this is essentially the
idea if you bring money and investment
into the uk they open the doors right
for you the question that comes up is
what kind of impact do these schemes
have on the general economic life is
this tier 1 visa beneficial to the
country or not
according to the british government
itself the purpose of this type of visa
is to increase investment and the
capitalization of companies registered
in the united kingdom in this way the
economy becomes more competitive and job
creation increases this benefits the
middle and sometimes working classes the
more companies there are the more robust
they are and the better it is for
everyone as a result the british golden
visa can be considered as a dynamizing
element for the economy we are talking
about a tool that has managed to attract
tens and tens of billions of pounds of
productive investment into the united
kingdom
which all sounds great doesn't it of
course these types of schemes also have
their weaknesses many detractors
criticize them for being a kind of safe
conduct for large fortunes whose wealth
may have been obtained shall we say not
very cleanly to say the least in
countries where the rule of law and
control are conspicuous by their absence
on the other hand they can also act as a
refuge for many rich people who thanks
to these kind of visas are able to
escape from tyrants of all kings
[Music]
be that as it may the question that
concerns us most today is another one
guess who have been the investors most
favored by the uk tier one visas well
it's the chinese and the russians
especially the russians the latter have
in fact become quite the headache for
downing street have you ever heard of a
london grant no let's take a closer look
welcome to london brad
[Music]
in 2015 the russian television channel
sts launched londongrad a tv sitcom
about an agency specializing in solving
problems for russian millionaires living
in london sounds hilarious a plot that
as random as it may seem to us is not
really random at all perhaps its
storylines are not all that far fetched
[Music]
see of the approximately 12 000 holders
of british gold and visas around 20 of
them are russians obviously there's an
explanation for this and for that you
have to go back to the period from 2008
to 2015. this was a period known as i'm
not making this up blind faith let's say
that back then the program had few
requirements and above all there were
hardly any checks in place to know who
the beneficiaries of the golden visas
really were and where their fortune came
from
and of course if we mix all these
ingredients in the same shaker russians
millionaires and few checks what do we
get we get the oligarchs
[Music]
suddenly the british tier 1 visa model
became a magnet for russian fortunes so
much so that in the seven years between
2008 and 2015 85
of all golden visas were granted to
russian investors but of course when the
requirements were tightened the flow of
arrivals from the russian motherland
slowed down a lot curious since 2015
russians only account for 15 of the
visas granted it's still a huge
percentage but it's not quite so crazy
anymore and i'm sure none of you are
surprised it's as if many of the russian
millionaires looking to invest and live
in the uk were not really happy to have
their affairs snooped into i mean i
don't know why but it also doesn't
surprise me
the fact is that there was a moment when
the british government realized that
something was going wrong very very
wrong basically because the country was
filling up with vladimir putin friendly
oligarchs and with them the influence of
russian investments linked to the
kremlin government in the british
economy was also increasing for example
according to the organization
transparency international since 2016
more than 1.5 billion pounds that's 1.64
billion dollars went into the country's
real estate assets have been bought in
the country by high-ranking russian
officials and oligarchs linked to the
kremlin and what is certain is that the
true figure taking into account the
opacity with which these people operate
could be much much higher and of course
this is just one example
so you can believe us when we tell you
that this from a geostrategic point of
view is not the best idea in the world
not to mention that many of these people
are used to doing and undoing things as
they please not only related to their
own affairs but also to other peoples
for them things like the rule of law
competition or free business well what
can i say they sound like imperfections
resulting from western softness it's a
culture that is not exactly good for the
general business climate there are even
reports that many of these oligarchs
have tried to influence british politics
itself that is the same thing they do
back home in russia you know what they
say old habits die hard
[Music]
so in 2015 the british authorities began
to change and tighten access conditions
while improving checks a retroactive
investigation was even initiated of more
than 6 000 golden visas yeah that's not
a mistake about half of all those issued
have been or are being reviewed and
their holders are being investigated
there is for example the case of roman
abramovich
[Applause]
abramovic is a well-known russian
oligarch and owner of the chelsea
football club who in 2018 withdrew his
application for renewal of the visa
because he was being increasingly
investigated for his business dealings
in the end he opted for israeli
citizenship and also we have the case of
alexander petrachenki a russian
millionaire who entered the uk through
his wife and then was granted a golden
visa despite the fact that he was being
investigated by interpol at the time for
fraud money laundering and abusive power
[Music]
[Applause]
but not only russians can be found on
this controversial list we also have
characters such as india's nirav modi a
billionaire who is in the midst of
extradition proceedings for money
laundering and for allegedly
perpetrating a two billion dollar fraud
against the indian bank pnb or a bunch
of kazakh ukrainian and even bangladeshi
millionaires politicians and oligarchs
come on the uk only accepts the finest
from around the globe the one thing they
all have in common is having received
their visa during the blind faith period
now the heightened vigilance the
investigation of russian millionaires in
the uk has become even tougher since
2018 does anyone remember what happened
in the uk that year no check this out
wealthy russians in britain face new
visa crackdown after salisbury that's
right in 2018 there was the case of the
poisoning of former russian spy sergei
skripal and his daughter both poisoned
with nova chalk by two russian agents
nova joke for those of you who don't
know is a russian poison developed
during the soviet era by the way we've
left you a link in the description below
where we give you another video about
all the details of how this poison is
used in modern russia the point is the
united kingdom realized that the
presence of russian oligarchs close to
president putin could end up becoming a
bit of a national security problem
london status as a playground for
kremlin linked oligarchs undermines
britain's tough on russia stance britain
isn't the only country in which
oligarchs store money nor are russians
the only ones who park illicit money
abroad but the ukraine crisis has led
the british government to try to square
the contradictions between its foreign
policy and london's loose oversight the
united kingdom was decisive in imposing
sanctions on russia however it was not
so nimble with the oligarchs this is
something that has even been denounced
by the conservative newspaper the times
see for yourselves
3rd of march 2022 the uk's dietary
process with sanctions is beginning to
be a source of embarrassment and a
matter of political concern remember
that the money of the great russian
oligarchs linked to the kremlin has
enriched among many others law firms
bankers architects and entrepreneurs in
the hospitality and luxury good sectors
genuine economic dopamine that sometimes
slows down difficult decisions
[Music]
be that as it may it is clear at this
time everything is different and the
british and generally the european
playground of the great russian fortunes
may be coming to an end
there is no place for dirty money in the
uk those back in putin have been put on
notice there will be nowhere to hide
your ill-gotten games boris johnson
prime minister of the united kingdom but
now it's over to you do you think that a
golden visa system would be beneficial
for your country should recipients be
carefully filtered or should such
schemes be open to any investor leave us
your opinion below in the comments and
if you liked this video don't forget to
like it so we know and of course
subscribe to us here on visualpolitik as
well as hitting the little bell down
there so you receive notifications and
don't miss any of our videos all the
best and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you